das ist ohne scheiß nun richtig hartes
gefahren
also habe ich das sagen klar so ein
richtig hart typisches gefressen das ist
einfach so sie sind das ipad was geht ab
und herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video heute ich hoffe natürlich jedes
gut ja eine andere klasse erinnert es
gab es noch mal von mir videos ich teste
food neuheiten essens neuheiten aus dem
letzten monat oder auch generell aus dem
letzten jahr das habe ich schon ziemlich
lange nicht mehr gemacht dafür mir aber
das kann ich eigentlich mal nachholen
weil es gibt einfach wieder so unfassbar
viele neue sachen ich war ungefähr eine
stunde in zwei supermärkten einkaufen
und hätte noch viel mehr mitnehmen
können also das ist denn jetzt aber
erstmal die acht sache nämlich am
meisten angesprochen haben und ja das
kam alles so aus in den letzten 12
monaten ich freue mich sehr dass jetzt
mal testen zu können wir haben hier
kinder pinguin cherry kinder bringen
habe ich immer als kind gegessen hat die
normale variante
und hier ist jetzt kirche drin oder hier
limited edition crunchy karamell m & m
südlich wird sagen lassen wir einfach
damit anfangen das ist im hotel stranger
karamell
das war auf jeden fall anders geplant
aber die sehen aus wie ganz normale
modems also auch von der größe her
schmeckt schon so ein bisschen
weihnachtlich eigentlich ultraleicht ich
weiß nur dass wenn ich davon so zehn
stück essen würde mir wird schon
schlecht gehörten aber die kann ich euch
auf jeden fall mal erzählen ich weiß
nicht ob ich glück hatte die zu finden
weil da war noch zwei packungen da ein
fehlt noch ich würde sagen wir machen
hier mit weiter das habe ich auch
gefunden sieht ultra wird aus oder so
auf den ersten blick das ist eine
mischung aus dem schokoriegel und diesen
cookie keksen ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen auf der verpackung sieht das so
ein bisschen misslungene aus oder voll
komisch sehr schlicht gehalten
aber eigentlich ganz nach kassel vorne
fehlt anscheinend an schokolade und das
ist jetzt einfach ein cookie keks mit
schokolade überzogen oder so dass sie
hier sind eigentlich schoko stücke drin
weil meinem wo ich jetzt ein gewissen
habe sind die allerdings weiß es geht da
muss ich leider sagen hat mich jetzt
nicht so ganz überzeugt fand ich jetzt
nicht so lecker leider aber wir haben ja
auch noch andere milchprodukte
das ding ist ich weiß dass noch aus dem
letzten jahr als ich das manchmal
gemacht habe es gibt einfach andauernd
neue mini cabrio produkte die arbeiten
ja immer zusammen oder ist es auch eine
company und das hört einfach nicht auf
wir haben hier orio minis original dann
hier noch milka kuh die sensation oreo
und werte es gedacht dieser nikolaus auf
white chocolate bioethischen neu sind
aber auch noch diese nimmt zwei
gefüllten kartons da ist nämlich cola
drin da sonst kennt man das ja immer nur
mit irgendwelchen bruch geschmäckern
oder so also hier haben wir im 2 ich
glaube das ist kirsche oder erdbeer was
auch immer und hier ist jetzt cola davon
also die sind nicht schlecht keine frage
kann man essen aber ich find die
original viel viel leckerer eindruck
dieser cola geschmack passt nicht so ich
tue mich sowieso meistens schwer mit so
cola geschmack in irgendwie gummibärchen
zeugs keinen fall nicht aber das hier
geht auf jeden fall klar also ist nicht
ich muss jetzt auf jeden fall geben
kinder bringen probieren das wird auf
jeden fall ja gerade weil ich die früher
immer gegessen habt wird das schon jetzt
was besonderes für mich sein sieht aus
wie immer aber ist es halt nicht
also zumindest von drin
freiheit schmeckt nicht
da passt nicht bleibt einfach bei der
ganz normalen variante des ultra lecker
aber das ist so das schmeckt sowie auf
zwang einfach was neues ausprobiert
würde ich mir nie im leben wieder kaufen
wenn ihr die schon mal probiert habt und
die geil findet könnte es gerne
kommentieren aber mein fall ist das
nicht dass wir hier mit weitermachen ich
weiß wir haben noch nicht mal
ansatzweise nikolaus aber das ist ja
ganz normal dass es solche sachen dann
hat oktober gibt da vielleicht auch
schon im september ich weiß nicht die
haben wir jetzt einfach ich muss den
ganz auspacken
sowas ist sie auch ein bisschen so aus
als hätte der eine krankheit oder als
wird der schimmel vielleicht oder es
sich halt leicht ungewohnt aus aber
vielleicht schmeckt er umso besser muss
ich sagen wirklich ultra nice ich bin
sowieso ein fan von weißer schokolade
und dann auch mit diesem bisschen urio
dazwischen kann ich euch absolut
empfehlen auch wenn es halt noch ein
bisschen früh ist aber an sich leute was
geht ganz kurzer cut und zwar wollte ich
erst mal die situation nutzen einige
wollen wir schon gestern gesagt haben
und das mal ganz kurz machen weil wir
menschen in letzter zeit es gibt hier
immer von montag bis freitag sind jeden
tag wieder ein video ich war eine lange
zeit nicht ganz so aktiv und jetzt will
ich mich aber irgendwie da gefunden und
keine ahnung das macht mir wieder so
viel spaß wie früher oder eigentlich
noch mehr zurzeit einfach weiß ich auch
mein eigenes büro und alles ist ja für
meine eigene wohnung es ist nicht immer
ganz leicht als einzelpersonen jeden tag
auch nur video des video zu drehen
videos zu schneiden und so weiter dass
noch alles ich selber deswegen wäre es
super cool wenn ihr wie früher einfach
mir gerne aber instagram weitere ideen
stadt oder auch hier in die kommentare
einfach so wenn euch irgendwas beweg was
ich vielleicht noch besser machen kann
was ich anders machen kann wenn ich
irgendwas man unbedingt machen soll
irgendwas testen sollen
würde ich mich freuen wenn ihr mich
gerne schaut dass die mir das einfach
mal schickt oder schreibt eine kurze
nachricht das motiviert einem aber umso
mehr und das war's schon also wie gesagt
merkt euch das montag bis freitag immer
neun zehn und dreißig ist hier weiter
mit dem video
okay wir haben jetzt hier als nächstes
noch nix ja es gibt viele leute die
lieben die und es gibt viele leute die
mögen die auch nicht so gerne ich gehöre
zu den leuten die sie schon sehr gerne
essen das sind halt wirklich so dinger
damit hengste einmal an und kann sich
mehr aufhören
und sie gibt es jetzt auch in doppelter
größe ich frage mich nur ist es
vielleicht ein bisschen zu groß
also ich muss sagen ich habe mir die
schon deutlich größer vorgestellt weil
man hatte auch oft in der normalen
verpackung manchmal so ausreißer die
noch größer waren als die hier jetzt
also an sich erstmal nichts besonderes
[Musik]
schmeckt halt absolut wie immer
da macht es keinen unterschied ob er die
kauf- oder die normalen ist eigentlich
das gleiche dann haben wir jetzt hier
noch diese cookies sensation orio
edition also cookies mit orio creme
füllung
na da sind ja viele drin 12 36 stück für
zwei euro 70 oder so ist schon nicht
günstig aber vielleicht sind ja ihren
preis wert das ist ohne scheiß so ein
richtig hartes kiffer also darf ich
sagen klar so ein richtig hart typisches
gefahr essen das ist einfach so in ist
dieses wirklich lecker hier drin ist
diese erfüllung und damit dem kuki schon
nice also das will mich ist es halt
einfach so
produkt was kümmert es ja gut also echt
nice weiter geht's gut dass es jetzt
eigentlich das langweiligste orio minis
original mit schokolade umzogen
hier gibt's den autor mit weißer
schokolade
aber ach und noch mal verpackt alter
irgendwie kommen die mir so bekannt war
als hätte ich dir schon mal probiert
auch sehr sehr nah ist keine frage also
wir haben ja eigentlich nur sachen die
lecker sind außerhalb kinder pinguins
mir schmecken die nicht für mich wäre
das nichts und halte diese cola nimmt
zwei dinger sind jetzt auch nicht so
ganz meins den rest kann ich euch
absolut empfehlen das was eine schon
wenn ich noch mehrere partys machen soll
in zukunft also es gibt so viele neue
sachen das echt krass lass mir super
gerne daumen nach oben da und wir sehen
uns morgen um 19 uhr wieder abonniert
den kanal das was von mir
haut rein